[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So here
we are in the Sandbox.
I'm so glad that you'll be
here with us for the next three
days, as we explore everything
on the ground at Google I/O.
First off is the Mocktail Mixer.
It's not getting started early,
because there's no alcohol.
Chris, would you
tell me about this?
CHRIS: Excellent.
Thanks, Timothy.
So this was a
do-it-yourself mixer
that has the Google
Assistant built in.
It was part of a collaboration
between the Assistant team
and Deeplocal, these
guys behind you.
It's a creative agency
out of Pittsburgh.
And what they've done is they've
used the Google Assistant
SDK, which we launched
three weeks ago,
and Actions on Google to
customize the drink, the drink
ingredients, and the code, as
well as services like API.AI,
to create a conversational
interface so you
can have a natural
interaction with the mixer.
So it's a super demo.
It shows you how to go
from zero to prototyping
in a matter of hours.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, I want
to talk a little bit more
about this demo and the
SDK and all the things
that we can do with it, but
first let's make a drink.
CHRIS: You want to make a drink?
Let's give it a shot.
Let's talk to Mocktails Mixer.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
Here is the test version
of Mocktails Mixer.
SPEAKER 2: Hi.
I'm your Mocktails Mixer.
CHRIS: What's on the menu?
SPEAKER 2: On tap today, I have
a pairing mode and Mang-I/O.
What can I get you?
CHRIS: Let's get a pairing mode.
SPEAKER 2: Coming right up.
Initiating ones and zeros.
Beep boop, bop, boop boop.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is that the
robot sounds it's making?
CHRIS: Yeah, so
it's actually like--
it's going from my voice,
going through this mike,
through the Assistant SDK,
running on a Raspberry Pi
device-- which I think Oscar
will talk a little bit more
about--
going back to the
Assistant services server
running in the cloud, and
figuring out what I'm saying,
doing natural language
understanding and speech
recognition, and then
basically coming back
and controlling the devices.
And now you see we've started
making the pairing mode drinks
for everybody around here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
OK, there's a bunch of drinks.
So, we have some other
friends joining us.
Let's start with Oscar.
Oscar, you're one of the guys
that actually built this.
OSCAR: Yeah, so I
work for Deeplocal.
We worked, like Chris said, with
the SDK team on the project.
And basically,
the way this works
is there's a Raspberry Pi inside
the device that runs the SDK.
And when you speak with
it, it runs up to API.AI,
where you can program your
conversational interface.
From there, there's
a web hook that's
called that, when
you call a drink,
it pushes a message over Google
Pub/Sub down to the devices,
and actually sends a serial
command to the Arduinos inside.
That is actually what
controls the motors
and dispenses the liquid.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That was, like,
a design doc in five sentences.
Thank you.
OSCAR: Yeah, exactly.
And everything is open
source and online,
so you can find it on GitHub
if you search for Mocktails
Mixers, or if you go to
Deeplocal.com/mocktailsmixers,
there's a write-up and a
video and DIY instructions
so the home builder
can make it themselves.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's Wayne.
Wayne, you're the home builder.
WAYNE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So Wayne, you are
one of the developer
advocates working on Assistant
and the SDK and all these APIs.
Is this what you
do all the time?
WAYNE: Well, I made a dog feeder
one time, but this is new.
I've got to get into this now.
I can imagine something
where you can, like,
mix up custom food or
something like that.
That'd be kind of cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You
made a dog feeder.
They made a human feeder.
WAYNE: Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're
gonna merge them together now,
right?
That's the cool thing
is, because this SDK is
available to the public, anyone
can build devices like this
now.
I'm quite excited about it, too.
So I need to go home and
work out my next plan
for some kind of dog feeder.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
that's the really cool thing
about this recent release.
Like, the SDK just came
out a few weeks ago, right?
Three weeks ago?
And it's really giving
the ability for people
to bring the Assistant
into their own hardware.
WAYNE: Yeah, exactly.
I mean, you can take any
crazy idea that you've got,
and you can embed the
Assistant SDK into it,
run it on-- runs on most Linux
operating systems and so forth.
And it's just really
easy to get started.
And we've got a whole
bunch of samples.
People can try it out.
All the demos here--
we have other demos,
as well-- they're
all open source
so people can try them out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
again, just like
sort of taking a look at the
value of that, it's really--
this is something that people
have been doing before,
but they had to build the
whole stack themselves, right,
which includes a
lot of technologies
that they don't want to
really be experts in.
But Google can be
the expert for them,
and you can just use
the APIs instead.
WAYNE: You can focus on
what you're good at, which
is making these
kinds of devices,
and leave all the
speech recognition
and the natural language
understanding to us,
and we take care of it for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Are the drinks ready?
Oh, I see they're
getting poured out.
CHRIS: [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
well while we're
waiting for the drinks, Vera,
tell me about some of the ways
that people are using
the Assistant today.
VERA: Awesome.
So today at I/O, we announced
that the Assistant is
fundamentally conversational.
So everything that
we're seeing here
that Wayne mentioned, that it's
natural language processing,
you're able to actually, as a
user, talk to the Assistant,
and the Assistant can
do things for you.
And so the Assistant is live
across devices like this
through our open SDK, but
it's also live across Android.
And we announced an iOS app, so
you can get it on your iPhone.
And it's also live on wearables,
and soon TVs, cars, et cetera.
And the Assistant can--
so as a part of our developer
platform, Actions on Google,
the Assistant can
order cows for you,
or make table reservations,
or even up your smart home
so it can clean your apartment.
And so we're really
excited about what
developers will build on top
of the platform to help users.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
I think the drinks are ready.
CHRIS: Do you want to drink it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I sure do.
VERA: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is the--
which drink is this?
CHRIS: Pairing mode.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Pairing mode.
I get it.
VERA: Cheers, guys.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
pretty fantastic.
I'm impressed.
WAYNE: It tastes better because
it was made with technology.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What was that?
WAYNE: It tastes better because
it was made with technology.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
absolutely right.
CHRIS: We're putting artificial
intelligence into your drinks.
Done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I'm gonna
drink a little bit more
of this, but maybe while
I do that, can you talk
about where you see this going?
Like, what are you most
excited about developers
doing with this technology?
CHRIS: Yes, it's
a great question.
So what we envision is a
ubiquitous system experience
so that, when you need
help or need something
to be done in your life, that
you can just ask the question
and it will happen, right.
So for that experience
to really surface,
you need to have the
Assistant in multiple places
in your life.
And we don't expect
a Google Home
to be in every
corner of your house,
and we also don't expect Google
to build all the appliances
in your house.
It just doesn't make any sense.
So what we need to do is we need
to empower a diverse ecosystem
of device
manufacturers embedding
the Assistant in their devices.
Then you can have the
Assistant available to you
when you need it, wherever you
need it, however you need it.
So that's really where we
see this going longer-term
in the Assistant SDK, and
Actions on Google and API.AI
are just the beginnings
of where we're going.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much.
Thank you, everybody.
And to you all
out there, cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]